Thank you very much.
Welcome to my talk about coding kids and screaming
carrots.
Just to be sure, I'm talking about kids from
6 12 years and I hope you enjoy it.
My name is Georgios Kaleadis.
I'm 34 years old.
I live in Munich and I'm a frontend developer.
In my spare time I teach coding to kids, and
I'm origami addicted since it was taught to
me in front of Osaka castle nearly two years
ago in Japan.
Today and nearly every day, and I created
a project about virtual origami folding.
So, let's start.
And first I'm going to start with me as the
coding kid.
To make sure you have the proper image, that's
me.
I'm 10 years old.
It's 1994.
I called this, this is the holder for a reason.
At the time I loved to play with the Super
Nintendo and Sega Game Gear.
And I loved to be with the shelves of magazines.
And they had them attached, and the ones with
computers had applications and trials and
patches.
Why?
Because the Internet was not available to
everyone.
And could you use them?
Not at all.
I didn't own a computer.
I got in touch with real computers when my
sister took me to an agency office.
And I got to tinker around with a Mac OS9.
Photoshop was my favorite application.
I created dozens of galaxy spirals.
And jump to 1997, the year of my first PC.
Actually, I had to wait until Christmas 1997.
It's now three years since my first magazine.
My computer is running Windows 95 and had
a 4-gigabyte hard disk.
And what does a kid do with a brand-new computer?
Playing games.
It's 1998 and I enjoyed my computer day and
night.
My very first game I bought was Blade runner.
It was distributed and took up half of my
disk space.
Let's go ahead to 1999.
The year I got my Internet access.
I had a 56K modem to connect, which was slower
than your frontal data plan on your smartphone.
Let's listen to the iconic sound for a quick
flashback.
If I can get sound.
[modem sounds ahhh... memories...]
[ Applause ]
Yeah.
And I still can't believe that the Internet
worked back then.
This is some random day in April 1999.
I was watching my favorite TV station called
NBC Giga.
They usually talked about games and computers
all day long.
This particular day they were showing us a
brand-new application for creating animations.
They let a red ball bounce around.
It must have looked like this.
And I was impressed.
They mentioned the name of the application,
but I didn't write it down.
After school I wanted to search for the version
on all of my magazines.
But I forgot the name.
The week went by quickly.
It is Saturday.
Which means getting up as early as possible
and watching series like Saber Rider, Captain
Future or Duck Tales.
And around lunchtime, watched Giga TV again.
I could not believe it, it was repeated from
earlier in the week.
I was frozen and held my breath and waited
for the moment they would tell met name I
forgot.
And then there it was on the TV screen.
It was called Macromedia Flash 4.
And just now, with Flash, this was the genesis
of my whole programming career.
Flash looks like this.
There's a timeline, some layers and tools.
And, of course, the stage where things move
around.
I quickly found a place to code.
And soon I was able to program the very famous
menu.
It's a horizontal navigation with the illusion
of infinity.
And I was so good at programming that thing
that I could go to agencies to earn my first
money.
It was an amazing time full of amazing websites.
You see here the portal.
Yes, this is a website.
And stuff like this drove my ambition to get
me where I am today.
So, what's my point, you are asking?
Well, remember the genesis of my programming
career in front of the TV?
I wish I would have had some guidance during
school so that more than a single moment in
front of the TV would have guided me to my
career.
That's the most I had in school, this.
Later, computer classes were like this.
And computer classes today are [audio breaking
up] I want to be and change the things.
That's why I began teaching coding in my spare
time.
And I wanted to teach how you can contribute
to.
So, for the next 20 minutes I will talk about
how to teach and where to teach it.
So, why do for kids let's start with something
easy.
We all can describe to a child how is more
or less, right?
We can even tell how it works.
But when you press a play button on a video,
yeah.
What would you tell that kid?
It's hard for many of us.
It's like something is missing in school.
So, let's fix this for our children by teaching
coding to kids.
The whole world is talking like that.
It's like people are concerned about the future
of our kids or that we fear that technology
leaves us behind.
But no matter what, the command is the same.
Our kids should learn coding.
This is justified.
I'm biased in this question for obvious reasons.
So, let's step back and take a look at the
bigger picture.
We start by looking at the mechanic and apply
the whole coding discussion on to it.
And it goes like this.
It's sort of like an obsession with being
an auto mechanic.
There's tons of cars and there's tons of driving.
But I think it's a little silly and go and
say that everyone should really learn to be
an auto mechanic just because cars are so
essential to the functioning of our society.
Yeah.
It would be silly, indeed.
But what do we do?
There's tons of technology and we go around
and tell everybody how important coding is.
So, are we silly, then?
Or are we just talking about something else
than coding?
What if the word "Coding" is born out of confusion?
The question is, what do people actually mean
with coding?
In 1943 Konrad Zuse built the famous Plankalkul
and together with it, the very first programming
language.
It looked like this.
And the technology escalated pretty quickly.
With this, you hold the device that combines
everything we learned in the past 70 years.
That's a lot of very complex.
It makes computer science not easy to talk
about.
Coding on the other side is easy, take someone
at the keyboard and watch that person give
commands to the computer.
That's coding and people understand it.
If coding is such an easy word, maybe that's
why it's mixed up.
Let's try a theory, when people talk about
coding, they actually mean technology.
And people demand our kids not to learn coding.
They're saying our kids need to learn technology.
And the whole coding discussion suddenly makes
sense.
It's not about coding anymore.
It's about exposure to technology, computer
science and programming.
So, kids can understand the bigger picture
and the connecting lines.
Most of the kids will never be a coder anyway.
Our children should learn that smartphones
and technology are not magical.
That there are limitations, benefits and possibilities
for using them.
Teaching coding still makes sense.
It's only one part of understanding technology.
But you benefit in many ways when you learn
to code.
As a coder, you make the transition from being
a consumer to a producer who can tell stories
and create your own worlds in the computer.
Coding stretches your mind.
And it creates a thinking which is useful
in depends.
The room for creativity is endless like painting
and music, but often more accessible and affordable.
And speaking of affordable, coding gives you
chances.
Computers are cheap nowadays, poor children
can afford it.
Everybody can become a coder today.
So, I hope I've convinced you by now why teaching
coding matters.
Let me show you some possibilities how to
teach coding.
I will present you now a list of my favorite
tools I love to use when teaching.
It's about tinkering, robots and actual coding.
Let's have a look at tinkering.
This is all about playing around with electronics.
For example, with a robot.
This is a toy that every kid starting at 4
years can build by themselves.
The parts cost less than 2 Euros.
There's a battery and a rotating motor.
When activated, the robot will vibrate and
start walking around drawing on the underlying
surface.
This looks like real art in the end, and it's
so much fun for the kids to watch their robot
to be alive.
And making it, its simplicity is just awesome.
The MakeyMakey is a board that presents to
be a computer keyboard.
When they get close, they close a circuit
on the MakeyMakey and you press a defined
code on the computer.
What can you do?
Build a Super Mario controller.
Find a Mario game that you can control with
the keyboard.
And you can be productive and design your
own game controller to move and jump.
Our next tool, robots.
Many of them can be programmed with the child
friendly programming language.
Let me show you some.
Say hello to Dash & Dot.
Those are robots with many censors, LSDs and
speakers.
Together they cost around 200 Euros.
And to play with them, you can use it so that
everything is about exploring and adventures.
You don't create programs, but have missions
by using commands for light, sound and movement.
This also is where you have more of a coding
experience.
This gives the kid a focus on their own creativity
with the robots.
And my favorite robot.
He's open source.
You can theoretically create all parts yourself
and use the software for free.
You can, of course, buy it as a package for
80 Euros.
And what's special about it?
That the kid will assemble it.
Usually within 20 minutes.
You can then start an automatic program, use
an app or code your own program.
When you activate the autonomous driving mode,
it uses the sensor to follow a line and avoid
obstacles in front of it.
Let's look at how coding is being taught.
You usually tackle it in three different parts.
Analog activity, playing games, and dive into
the actual coding experience.
Let's look at the analog activity.
If you want to control a robot, you have to
behave like a robot first.
So, it's playing the human robot game.
One kid all year dresses up as a robot.
A helmet is usually enough for the illusion,
but the full costume like this is never wrong.
You explain the kids around that they can
only use five commands to control the robot.
Forward, turn left, turn right, backward and
stop.
So, let's begin.
Imagine this task.
You want the robot to turn to the right and
walk in that direction.
So, you begin with a turn right, right?
Let's see what happens after the kids yelled
that command to the robot.
The robot will spin forever and ever and ever,
of course.
The command was correct, but not exact enough.
They should have said turn right for a quarter.
While spinning around, somebody will hopefully
scream a releasing step to the desperate robot.
In the end, kids really love that game.
Collaborate and understand the limits of a
machine.
They also understand the requirement of exact
commands and to put one command after another
just like in programming.
Your crowd is ready for some more fun.
Let's play some coding games.
There's some rules in our Hour of Code to
do so.
There are dozens of one-hour games and tutorials
translated in over 45 languages.
Everybody's encouraged to try it.
The games are themed after kid's games like
Princess Elsa or Minecraft.
And they teach the principles of programming
while playing.
I usually pick a game to follow up with the
human robot example.
This is a level where he has to be guided
to his favorite food, the level, and it's
a flower.
And you move with simple demands, move forward,
turn left, right.
Kids usually place one command after the other.
That's simple and it's working.
But it results in a huge list.
They can't even complete the level as they're
forced to use a new block to repeat commands.
I then show them a pattern of four blocks
they can repeat instead of the huge list.
Forward, left, forward, right.
And I point them to the pink repeating block.
And, success!
They usually just know what to do.
Pick the pink loop block and repeat the repeating
pattern inside.
It's now a small and beautiful block of code.
I love this moment.
I explain this is what it computer is for.
The computer should repeat the boring stuff.
It is not your task.
After the hour, the kids should have internalized
those block based commands and they are ready
for Scratch to do some real coding.
Scratch is the most famous tool in kid programming.
It was created by Mr. Resnick at MIT in 2002.
It can be used with Flash.
The next, version 3 is based on HTML 5 and
will be released in August.
Everything you code can be shared on the Scratch
website and remixed by others as the source
code is always accessible.
Let's have a look inside Scratch.
On the left you have a stage where everything
will move around.
And on the right, you see the coding theater.
That's where you code with colorful blocks.
This is called block based programming and
very easy to understand by children.
And to complete a section, I brought you something
special.
A screaming carrot, which is also part of
the sensational title.
It's programmed in Scratch and it will make
use of a MakeyMakey.
So, I will switch over to my application.
Let's try it if this is working.
yeah.
I will align myself.
Yeah.
This is setup I prepared.
And you will see momentarily what I've prepared
here because I am going to switch over into
webcam mode.
So, that's me.
And you should see now the hardware I've prepared.
The people in front should have problems,
the resolution is low.
I will explain it so you can fill the rest
of the image.
So, what you can see here is first of all,
a kitchen knife made of steel.
That's important.
The mandatory carrot.
You can see here two connecting cables.
They're called alligator clips.
And they are titled because they are looking
like an alligator.
And you have here the MakeyMakey.
I hope you can see it now.
It's this board.
And you can see some contact points.
You see some labeled with space or just arrow
keys mimicking the once on your keyboard.
And at the bottom, you see what is required
to close the circuit.
Let's use all that stuff.
Use the space key to connect it.
I will plug it into the carrot.
I will use the green to connect to the grounding
bar.
And I will plug it into the knife.
And what happens now is, when I touch the
carrot, I will align it here if I touch the
carrot, it will flow through the orange cable
into the carrot.
And back to the MakeyMakey, and the MakeyMakey
will tell the computer, hey, the space key
is pressed, and you can do fantastic stuff
with this.
I will connect it and show you what it's doing
at the moment.
You will see it heavily blink.
Which is a good sign.
Yep.
And if I attach it, you should see in the
lower right corner, space key pressed.
That's boring because I promised you something
even cooler.
So, let's do a quick live coding session.
Yeah.
[ Applause ]
So, that's pretty hard, over my shoulder.
But I will get there because I'm prepared.
So, this is the part which is showing the
issue.
And I will replace it with the sound I prepared.
Its code name is same sound.
And I plug it here.
And you can read it there, when space key
is pressed, play some sound until done.
So, let's see what's happen for I'm going
back into full screen mode.
I will show you the carrot.
Not.
It's coming my way.
Always failing.
Okay.
So, let's try it to cut a carrot.
I mean, it's a pretty big one.
[carrot screaming]
[ Applause ]
And I promise I will eat that carrot just
to save the moment.
So, let's get back into the presentation.
Okay.
What's left is the question where everybody
could try teaching coding.
I want to stress the word everybody.
You don't have to be a programmer.
Everybody can learn coding, and everybody
can teach about coding or robots.
I started teaching coding to kids in my spare
time exactly one and a half years ago.
They started in Berlin in 2016 and opened
an office in Munich in 2017.
This schedule is about coding with Scratch,
robotics, motion, and exploring the worlds
of Minecraft.
If you want to try it, just go like I did.
And you can host an Hour of Code even where
you play games like the zombie game and explain
programming to interested people.
And you may find an Hour of Code in your home
town.
Try to join and get in touch with the organizers.
And don't forget your family at home.
You can start teaching your own kids and relatives
easily with the tools I've shown you.
And you won't believe it, but designers, project
managers or maybe your clients are eager to
learn coding too.
They will have fun and understand you better
the next time you talk about bits and bytes.
Okay.
Enough about how, why and where to teach coding.
There's another important thing we didn't
talk about yet.
What about me, the teach center what do I
get?
Well, when did you play with toys for no reason
the last time?
It's healthy and it relaxes your mind.
It literally entertains the kid inside you.
And teaching coding makes not only the kids,
but you creative.
You need to think about what to do with a
MakeyMakey or create coding challenges in
Scratch.
Maybe you will use Scratch by yourself to
surprise someone special on their birthday.
If you are a coder, did you ever try to explain
someone programming?
Yes, it's very difficult.
You have to reflect on the very, very basics
of programming again.
But once you've mastered this, it will help
you throughout your whole mentoring career.
And working with kids is fun.
I always had an amazing time and I'm still
surprised about all the funny ideas they have.
You are full of knowledge now.
Use it.
A quick recap of what I've told you.
Coding mentors because it was never about
coding only.
But being exposed to technology, computer
science and programming.
So, kids can see the bigger picture and the
connecting lines between technologies.
But coding still makes sense.
Computers don't care who you are.
And many can afford it.
And coding boosts your creativity and is useful
in all demands.
And you know how to do it too.
By building robots and using a MakeyMakey
to make carrots scream, for example.
You know there are robots for kids like Dash
& Dot and they are easily programmable.
And finally, let the kids play the human robot
game followed by the zombie to prepare them
for coding in scratch where they unleash their
creativity.
And you know you can teach at the place you
started with locations around Germany, or
you decide to host or join an Hour of Code
event.
And you can start using your family at home
or make your office happy by teaching people
a bit about coding.
And there's one last thing I want to tell.
I still remember my very first time I taught
kids.
The glowing in their eyes when they connected
the pieces and finally understood what I teach
them.
And this is why I stand in front of you today
and I want you to experience the same and
have some kids finding their way through technology.
You can kind the slides and the link list
on this URL.
Thanks lot for listening.
[ Applause ]